this next story almost doesn't even require
doing because it's so obvious and it has always
been obvious, but Republican Senate majority
leader Mitch Mcconnell is now saying that
even though he said it would have been wrong
to fill a supreme court seat during Barack
Obama's last year of his second term back
in 2016 he actually would fill a hypothetical
Supreme Court opening next year 2020 which
by the way is the last year of Donald Trump's
presidential term.
He would not suggest if there is a vacancy
next year that we wait for the results of
the 2020 election so that we can let voters
have a say in the direction that they want.
The Supreme Court to go in words almost don't
even have the ability to express the brazen
and sort of vile political nature of this
entire conversation.
But I do think we should have the discussion
so we can file it and refer back to it when
we need to in the future.
And I'm sure that we're going to need to refer
back to it in the future.
So remember that back in 2016 right wing Supreme
Court, Justice Antonin Scalia died.
This created a vacancy on the supreme court.
Barack Obama was the president at the time,
and Barack Obama nominated Merrick garland.
Now Merrick Garland was no far left guy.
He was a centrist jurist and completely uncontroversial
in relation to the status quo.
Anyway, in basically every way the Senate
has to confirm Supreme Court nominees, Mitch
Mcconnell was in charge of the Senate in the
same way that he's in charge now, and Mitch
Mcconnell blocked it.
They never even had confirmation hearings
for Merrick Garland.
Mcconnell at the time said, well, you know,
it's the last year of Barack Obama's term.
We don't know if a Democrat or a Republican
is going to win in November of 2016 so it
would be appropriate before we take up any
nominations for the supreme court.
We should let voters have a say about the
direction they want the country going and
let the winner of the 2016 election choose
Antonin Scalia, his replacement.
Now we knew that it was horse manure back
then.
Presidents or presidents for the full four
years of their term.
The last year is just one of the four years
of those four year terms.
And there is plenty of historical precedent
for Supreme Court confirmations in the fourth
year of a president's term.
We knew at the time, if it was a Republican
president in 2016 if the nomination had been
to replace Antonin Scalia with a wing judge
selected by a Republican president, Mitch
Mcconnell would have immediately held those
confirmation hearings.
They would have filled the seat and that would've
been it.
Now at a, uh, Kentucky Local Chamber of Commerce
event, Mitch Mcconnell was asked, this was
yesterday or the day before, uh, someone in
the audience said, should a supreme court
seat become available next year in 2020?
What is your position going to be about filling
that spot?
Meaning 2020 is the going to be the last year
of Donald Trump's term.
You said back in 2016 no, Supreme Court confirmations
in the last year of a presidential term.
What happens if the same situation comes up
in 2020 and McConnell simply says, after sipping
his iced tea during the event, oh, well, we
would just fill it, um, check out the video
online.
I don't want to play it because it's from
a local news station.
And even though I know that it would be well
within our fair use rights to play the video,
local news stations are insanely aggressive
with their copyright claims and I just don't
want to deal with it because it's bad for
the show.
Uh, but what he said is, oh, we would fill
that seat.
Now if you really want to see the deep depths
of this sort of post hoc logic that these
republicans are applying, just listen to the
explanation that was given by Mitch Mcconnell's
spokesperson for this double standard media
outlets.
Rightly went to Mitch Mcconnell's office and
they said, hold on a second.
Mitch Mcconnell did one thing during Barack
Obama's last year of his term, and he says
that he's going to do something totally different,
hypothetically, during the last year of Donald
Trump's term.
How does he explain this obvious political
gamesmanship?
And David pop, who is Mcconnell's spokesperson,
said, no, no, no.
There's a difference between 2016 and 2020
in 2016 Democrats had the White House, but
Republicans had the Senate in 2020 Republicans
will have the White House and Republicans
will also have the Senate.
That is not an explanation or in a sense like
it's an explanation, but what he's saying
is, oh, the reason that we would do it differently
in 2020 than 2016 is because we can, and we
control not only the Senate, but also the
White House.
So it's likely that we would be in favor of
whoever Donald Trump would nominate in 2020
but the sickest part of it is that the entire
room, or a lot of it laughed when Mitch Mcconnell
said, Oh, we would see, we would confirm that
person.
They're all in on the joke, like it's not
even something that they're hiding.
Everybody knew in 2016 that Mcconnell's explanation
was a dishonest one, and we knew that if the
same thing happened under a republican president,
they would just confirm the supreme court
pick and lots of Americans, I mean Republicans
too, they all understood that that was the
game being played.
And they're fine with it.
Like it's some kind of funny joke.
And meanwhile, remember those people who are
in the lead up to the 2016 election, people
on the left were saying, if it's not whoever
I really want, I don't care if it's Hillary
or Trump.
It's basically the same thing.
If it's Hillary or Trump, Trump's supreme
court picks.
Tell us why it's not the same.
And we will now have a conservative supreme
court for a long time and even longer time.
If Donald Trump gets reelected in 2020 and
this is where, this is why Republicans are
winning on the issue of the courts.
Republicans decades ago decided they recognize
the importance of the courts and they realized
whether it's the supreme court, whether it's
federal judges, whatever, uh, we need to focus
on this.
And the Republican Party has focused on it
and they're winning hugely on it.
And when you have a contingent of the left,
which said, Supreme Court, who cares?
Hillary Trump, they're both just too centrist
for me.
They're both too much to the right for me.
I don't care.
This is the result.
Okay, the bed has been made and now we're
sleeping in it.
And mostly it's the blame of the right, but
there's a little bit of the left that also
has to take some of the blame here.
And this is exactly the result that we predicted.
Let's hope that Donald Trump doesn't get a
supreme court vacancy to fill next year.
And then let's hope that someone else's voted
in in November of 2020 make sure you're following
the show on Instagram where we will be polling
the audience on an issue related to the Supreme
Court, instagram.com/ [inaudible]
David Pakman show.
And while you're there, follow me as well.
I'm David.
Got Acting on Instagram